when we heard hey do you want to have c
thomas howard
that was it
that was it yes right
and and then it's just like hey to
support the fact that the outsiders made
in 1983 is available today on 4k disc
and digital today the answer was yes and
we're thrilled to have here on the rich
eisen show see thomas howell on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line how are
you see thomas howell
rich how are you my man call me tommy
please okay tommy tommy i was going to
ask you that literally is the first
question
you know it's just it's just torture
having a name nobody knows what the hell
they call you well what is what does the
c stand for
christopher all right christopher thomas
allen but it's a it's a union thing my
father and i have the same name and
we're both in the same union and as a
young age instead of being a junior he
tagged me with a c and i got it i didn't
have a whole lot to say in it
okay you know nobody's ever called me c
okay and uh i've always been called
tommy all right tommy we have
established all that those are the
ground rules for the rest of this
conversation i love it um before we get
to the outsiders you were in e.t at how
old were you in e.t i think about 13
when i did that
my gosh so what was that's your first
movie you're 13 year old on the set with
spielberg and a reese's pieces eating uh
extraterrestrial and a flying bike and
all that stuff that ended up happening
what was that like for you
that was
well first of all you have to understand
my father is
a stunt coordinator and was a stunned
man his whole life he's still active and
and working so
i grew up on sets
and
it wasn't
um it wasn't a foreign thing for me when
i when i started to audition and go in
and meet these type of people and also
rich you have to understand that my
father was a professional bull rider for
12 years so i grew up with a cowboy
background i was you know planning on
being a cowboy myself so pressure to me
back then was you know i was i was
roping and getting on bulls going in and
meeting a guy talking about you know
making money
to speak was like that's not pressure at
all you know at that point and as a kid
you've got no responsibilities there's
no
i had no bills i had no worries it was
just
immense fun and and
the only reason i i think i got the job
was
uh because that that wall was previously
cast
and
god knows why but spielberg wanted that
character to smoke a cigarette in a
scene and uh
the the person they cast was a mormon
kid and his mom was like he's not going
to smoke a cigarette
and i i had the opportunity to go in the
room and meet stephen and uh when it
when it got to the point about the
cigarettes my father on the way down to
the audition it stopped by 7-eleven and
we grabbed a couple of marlboro packages
and i practiced lighting these
cigarettes and i pulled this crumpled
cigarette out of my pocket that did a 90
degree turn put it in my mouth and tried
to light it and he was like all right
kid you got the part
and i you know uh really planned on kind
of doing stunts and and not being an
actor but that led to
uh me having an agent and um
the process of of auditioning for the
outsiders which was an enormous process
i mean they they saw every single
person under the age of 20 i think you
know under the stars and uh
um that began and i was able to sort of
get that role and you know you go
a lot of people think how great you go
from spielberg to copenhagen
rich but i'm here to tell you it's all
downhill from there
come on because we had rob lowe on a
couple of years ago and he called it his
like college experience
being there now you were younger than a
college age being on the set there right
right you were 15. oh that we all had a
lot of firsts on that set rich there was
a lot of firsts for all of us and you
know it was a uh there was a real
fraternity that's what he called it to
some degree right you know and there was
a real competitive sense because um
coppola being a bit of a
um
just he was so smart and he created
um
a real competition between the socials
and the greasers we would have barbecues
on weekends basketball games planned
they'd show up and get out of a
limousine with their matching jumpsuits
and we'd get out of a pass van with
whatever we brought from home
you know they got leather binders we got
nothing they stayed on the 16 17 floor
we were on the third and the fourth and
they just created this sense
of animosity that of course was
you know to some degree friendly but
trust me when it come when it was time
to rumble we were sticking them with a
few you know what i mean so yeah so so
you know let's let's let's hit this uh
normally you know uh for these
interviews with a celebrity see thomas
howell uh we'll we'll ask you questions
that we've read about your career
personally on online or on wikipedia or
whatever and just do celebrity true or
false in that regard but i want to do a
celebrity true or false on the outsiders
uh certainly since in celebration of the
4k ultra hd digital uh release of the
film today hit it please we have a great
uh uh production value to it as well hit
it for c thomas
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth okay there you go right there
um first one up for you uh on celebrity
true or false for the outsiders see
thomas howell the iconic film poster was
supposed to be the greasers being
serious but they're all shown laughing
because ralph macchio made a joke about
leaf garrett standing off camera
true or false
very true
can you repeat the the the
joke real quick i'll tell you what
happened sure please
they have the social standing off
because they've done a couple of shots
of them um we're there grabbing our our
shots trying to you know go blue steel
and
uh in comes the platter of of sandwiches
and and um and deli meats and all that
and they put it down and the young
person bringing that in
uh he shouts out quite loudly hey you
know this is this is for the talent only
which meant for the actors
well
um
we go back to taking a few shots and
lake who wasn't in the room at that time
comes walking in and goes over to the
sandwich and ralph blurts out quickly
hey lace that's for the talent
and of course we all lost it and they
took a shot of that that was the
infamous poster wow
so what do we make of it that emilio
estevez still didn't crack his blue
steel what do we think of that he just
didn't yeah he's still so mad he's
staring down maybe he wanted the
sandwich maybe maybe maybe leaf took one
of his sandwiches maybe that's what that
is wow i love you know about emilio okay
uh so that you we already covered this
but i want to ask a little bit more uh
for the purposes of this segment here so
true it's true that during filming the
socials were given leather-bound scripts
you were in and were more luxury
accommodations than you you just had
paperback scripts and you had to stay
you were on the third floor because this
says ground floor of the hotel because
francis ford coppola wanted you guys to
already hate each other for the scenes
yeah no you know i think i've ruined our
game already it's okay
but so basically he did that that's true
well what did you guys did you guys
really like eventually throughout uh
filming get jealous of the other guys
for having better accommodations than
you did that really just genuinely piss
you off did it work no because because
you know i mean rich i i mean you know
it was like it wasn't a movie about the
socials you know what i mean it was like
they were all parading around with their
leather-bound scripts i was in front of
the camera grabbing close-ups
[Applause]
you know what i mean it was like i
didn't care at all i i had stuff to do
brother and and at that point it was
like
that that's what that's where the you
know
i was i wouldn't say i was mouthy but i
came from
a very confident background i mean in
1979 1980 1981 i was california state
all-around champion junior rodeo and i
was that was what i was gonna do so you
know i wasn't afraid to run my mouth to
somebody if that started and i was
pretty quick-witted so
you know somebody like lake garrett
having to listen to this little punk
who's kind of you know not taking any
golf from from you know the guy who's
jamming to his own cuts in the back seat
with his boombox was was a pretty good
was a pretty good thing to have to
witness so
we had a real competitive sense that you
know
um
was very interesting and i feel kind of
bad that uh you know
it at times
um
became that because ultimately i think
everybody loved each other but it was
really set up to you know to some degree
for us to to feel that and i think a
really good director does that and you
know all of the best directors create an
environment for their actors to go into
and i think that's why filming it in
tulsa oklahoma where it was written um
was was epic uh it took everybody out of
their
own comfort zone
and you know when you shoot a film or tv
show where you all live
there is no bonding after work you all
go back to your own lives and deal with
your own stuff and you bring all that
crap with you to work the next day but
in a situation like this we went back
home together and you know
we we were working together and i
remember rob lowe and patrick swayze
rest his soul i did three pictures with
patrick i did red dawn with him which
was epic
and we did uh
uh something that probably nobody ever
saw called grandview usa with jamie lee
curtis and
he was like a real brother to me um a
quick tale about patrick please uh my
father was a stunt coordinator in a
movie called urban cowboy i've heard
about travolta about riding the bucking
machine if you guys remember 78.79
and patrick swayze's mother patsy swayze
was the dance choreographer on that film
patrick was on that set working with
john a little bit with his two-step come
on and i was there
riding the bucking machine to help john
sort of
advance along and get over the fear of
it when he saw this little kid riding it
because my dad brought me down and i
would ride this bucking machine and
i met patrick when i was about oh i
guess 11 12 years old amazing um on the
set of urban cowboy was hanging out with
him and his family
probably two three years before
the outsiders ever even came around and
then we did three pictures together
travolta already had his saturday night
fever moment and we know obviously
swayze's maneuvers from dirty dancing
are you telling me that swayze helped
him
with moves on urban cowboys i'm telling
you that swayze was a big part of
teaching john that two-step with deborah
winger in that movie and he
also because john was so
john was beyond with the dancing but to
be really clear
patrick
stood in for john and would work with
deborah on her dancing as john because
john was advanced and ready to go you
know he was amazing he's not going to
really teach him a lot once he learned
the steps he was he was money but there
was still a process getting getting
deborah there and there's still a bit of
a process just teaching john the steps
and swayze was a big part of that how
about that
celebrity true or false an overachiever
man swayze was a classic overachiever
and in the most beautiful way i i i have
to tell you you know he just
the guy wanted to play the guitar in
sync number one song you know he
and i'll tell you this this is how
brilliant the guy is so a real quick red
dawn story um jennifer gray who was in
dirty dancing played baby
uh
the two of them didn't get along great
to be honest with you on red dawn in
fact
rich there was a there was a love scene
written in red dawn between swayze's
character and jennifer gray's character
and swayze really did not want to do it
and he offended her deeply
and it got down to the fact that when
they had to go to the directors and you
know millions had already worked with
swayze on uncommon valor so they were
pretty tight right
and swayze just felt it wasn't
appropriate for the film he says it's
not gonna move this story forward it's
not about that it was a big scene for
her a lot of dialogue and a big moment
so she was really bent out of shape and
we had about two or three weeks of
shooting left and the two of them didn't
really speak much
and i know she did not appreciate what
he what he had done there but he stuck
to his guns
and didn't feel was appropriate and i
think he was right here you go cut two
right couple years later
she's cast first in the role as baby in
dirty dancing they're searching up and
down for this guy johnny right to play
to play the the role opposite her they
can't find the guy they're looking
everywhere could you imagine the look on
her face when they finally say guess
what we found your guy oh my lord you're
gonna love this it's your friend patrick
swayze
the look on her face must have been oh
my god man and
what did swayze do
he turned that crap around then he made
an amazing movie and ever every that was
a huge hit that little movie of course
of course so he put baby in a corner
before baby was put in a corner yeah
that's what you're saying
and you know he just had the ability to
do that he was just classic over
achiever you know you could just say hey
i got a butterfly net i'm going to try
catching butterflies he's like well i
went to the olympics in 68 butterfly
kitchen wow i've never i never got to
meet patrick swayze i haven't
i have met jennifer gray out here in los
angeles she's a delightful person she's
a delightful person i've ever met you
would have loved patrick i bet all right
so returning to the outsiders uh
celebrity true or false i've got a
couple left here in the rumble scene
you were the first guy punched and you
got cold cocked it was a real punch true
or false
very true story so i'll try to answer
that quickly sure uh
i i we had choreographed for about oh
three four weeks this extensive stunt
fight this
this
elaborate sort of melee with a bunch of
people and
um i had you know a pretty good exchange
you know
two judo chops and some karate kicks and
whatever you do right so i was
practicing all that stuff getting ready
to do it we show up on the first night
it's a three-night shoot this whole
rumble the first night is sort of the
introduction you know getting us all
lined up and staring each other down
bringing everybody to each other and
kind of picking sides and saying i'll
take you i take you the next night was
gonna be the real beginning of the fight
the first night we get there rich it's
pouring rain and we're like what the
hell we gonna do
we shoot the whole thing in the pouring
rain we come back the next night there's
no rain but there's a fire department
there with with hoses just you know
smiles squirting us all night as we
begin
to rumble
the very first punch thrown
was from a friend of mine named reed
rondell he comes from a very well-known
stunt family called the rondelle
family
he
throws the first punch and slips in the
mud
and tagged me on the chin for real and
down i went as this melee took place
we cut i go over to friends and they're
like francis you know we got to do it
again i didn't get to do you know the
judo chops and the flips and the rolls
and all that stuff he's like no you got
it look like you got pounded in the face
and you went down in the mud it was
great i thought yeah that's what
happened he said yeah but that's what
happened now you got matt dillon
dragging me out out of the damn thing i
never got to throw a punch i just took
one of the chin and dropped and that was
that's what happened ponyboy in the damn
rumble
last one for you here uh in the scene uh
the fountain scene where leif garrett
attempts to drown you ponyboy apparently
later on after filming the uh six other
uh outsiders jokingly mocked the scene
in the lobbies uh the hotel that you
were seeing in the lobby fountain of the
hotel
trying to drown each other playfully and
the hotel removed the fountain after
that
is that a true story
well i will tell you this that first
part did happen
and
that fountain did disappear
why i don't know was it was it connected
i i it makes for a good story richard
well the writer of the uh s e hinton is
the person who told this story that the
hotel had the fountain removed within
weeks because they didn't want him
hilarious let me tell you one thing i
learned do not mess with s e hinton
period
that's it
what a great woman she was and imagine
this writing this thing when you're 17
years old in high school like she did
so basically i just i guess uh made you
learn something from celebrity true or
false based on this film he did how
about that because rob lowe also said he
turned he told us he turned 18 during
filming and you totally hazed him in his
hotel room like he saran wrapped his
toilet we did i think we did we did some
good stuff to him uh it was pretty it
was a prank oriented set a lot of things
happened you know
it was a
i do recall sort of
taking a fire hydrant and unscrewing the
eyepiece that you look through your you
know to see who's on the other side for
some reason yes in this hotel you could
unscrew it from the outside and i just
pumped a bunch of you know extinguisher
smoke into his room and phoned him and
said there was a fire and man he came
jetting downstairs with his camera and
in his skivvies and nothing else and we
had a pretty good laugh at that
but they got to me too they got they
they all pranked me pretty good i
remember one time i went home at four in
the morning and everything in my room
was turned upside down my bed everything
upside down it was horrible i wanted to
go to sleep so bad and i had to go get
another room for the day for them to fix
my room things like that were happening
all the time
last one back then you could do that
stuff richard i guess so now i sit in
the corner i'm quiet i can't say
anything man you you know you you used
to maybe be able to say something
inappropriate occasionally for a laugh
now man you are you are you are on your
best behavior there are there is no
jokes anymore brother last one for you
you want to ask it tj jefferson rich
eisen social media uh grand rapids shout
out to that go for it hey tommy i just
want to say i'm loving this interview um
the outsiders red dawn two of my
favorite movies i
couldn't even tell you how much i
watched these those two flicks but um
awesome i'm reading that flea from the
red hot chili peppers and cam neely were
they
in the movie with you guys as well or is
that a false uncredited socials is that
true that's false that's false okay
of red hot chili peppers and the great
cam neely they have it in imdb i think
cam nearly was in uh kingpin though i
think yeah
okay that's very good uh hey man see
thomas howell this has been great i'm a
big fan thank you for having me on the
show right back at you man congrats on
on on everything that's gone on in your
career and i appreciate you going down
memory lane with me here appreciate it
can't wait to meet you someday man keep
adding okay tommy there you go let's see
thomas howell right there on the rich
eisen show the outsiders go get it
i mean those photographs
uh are unbelievable that we just were
popping on the screen right there
unbelievable
diane lane was in it too yeah yes and
diane lane is just one of my favorites
of all time
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here